on leur a donné le week-end pour lui
dire adieu
quelques jours pour l'immortaliser
pour le décor et de fleurs et déposer
des chandelles c'est comme si toute la
ville de
Lettonie située à 30 km de la Russie
était en deuil
l'ambiance est digne d'un enterrement au
pied de ce monument érigé à la gloire
des soldats soviétiques
Larissa c'est très bien que c'est la
toute dernière fois qu'elle peut s'y
recueillir et elle est inconsolable
croyez moi
je viens déposer des fleurs ici pour le
jour de la victoire est-ce que le
gouvernement s'apprête à faire m'arrache
le coeur
du vandalisme
ce monument est le symbole de la
libération de la victoire de l'armée
rouge contre les nazis il est pour la
majorité en Lettonie l'emblème de
l'occupation soviétique qui a suivi la
deuxième guerre mondiale
par la Russie aura finalement eu raison
de leur destin
de la loi adoptée par le Parlement
laiton tous les monuments qui glorifient
le régime autoritaire qui était celui de
l'URSS doivent être retirés de l'espace
public d'ici la mi-novante les yeux
n'appré les autres les villes s'en
débarrassent la démolition du monument
de la victoire dans la capitale Riga au
mois d'août aura été la plus
spectaculaire de toutes et ce malgré
l'opposition de la minorité russophone
qui peuplent les pays baltes et qui
partagent une vision bien différente de
l'histoire
ou plus de 90% des résidences sont
d'origine russe on appréhendait une
telle scène la mairie a donc choisi de
le faire en pleine nuit mais pour Yulia
ce soir est un supplice
[Musique]
les émotions aussi entre la douleur et
la colère
est un souvenir il n'a rien à voir avec
un soutien pour la Russie c'est de la
politique et elle va beaucoup trop loin
des policiers ont été déployés pour
sévir contre toute personne qui oserait
afficher ses couleurs comme cette dame
qui porte un manteau sur lequel il est
écrit Russie
je ne suis pas pour la Russie ni contre
l'Ukraine je suis pour la paix dit-elle
quelques minutes plus tard elle était
retirée de la foule de force
les lois en Lettonie sont devenus
tellement sévères depuis le début de la
guerre
qu'aucun symbole de soutien pas
seulement à la guerre mais à la Russie
tout court n'est pas tolérée et donc on
a demandé à cette femme d'enlever son
manteau et la foule est complètement
outre
complètement absurde-t-elle alors qu'on
commence à retirer les fleurs pour faire
place aux démantèlement
[Applaudissements]
où sont des champs patriotiques de la
Grande Guerre qui aussi ne sont pas
tolérées ce soir les policiers
interviennent pour les temps
[Applaudissements]
de leur statue jusqu'à ce que les boules
de vos heures arrivent au petites heures
du matin
on ne sait pas si la statue ira au musée
ou encore au dépotoir
le monument n'est plus mais les temps
sont demeure et n'ont jamais été aussi
vide